you can no longer drive down a street
if you if the street has a pride flag
painted on it and you are not
sufficiently reverent toward the rainbow
stuff and the transgender whatever you
you're not allowed to drive down your
street that's a that's a hate crime this
is what a totalitarian society looks
like I use that word really really
carefully because a lot of times you'll
hear people on the left and on the right
use the word authoritarian I don't think
the word authoritarian really means much
of anything at all authoritarian just
means you wield your Authority when
you've got it that's what every state
has done for all of history but the word
totalitarian has a meaning the word
totalitarian means
that the regime's ideology has to
penetrate every single aspect of life
there can be no dissent ever in any way
not even private descent not even in
your local little Community you have to
go along with whatever the ruling party
says at every single level including
when you're driving down if you drive
down the street in a way that seems a
little Politically Incorrect that will
launch an investigation and a national
news story Chris Rock great comedian
just had a new Netflix special come out
and he took aim at what this sort of
totalitarian society looks like
everybody full of
you know I'm in my own neighborhood the
other day I into my my good
friend friend hadn't seen him in years
hadn't seen him in years Fred got a new
job at 18 T okay so I'm like hey Fred
how's the job and Fred's like oh I love
the job it's a safe space
I feel seen I feel heard there's a lot
of diversity and I'm looking at them
like
it's me
but you think I'm wearing a while
what the you talking about same
space
you've been eight years for manslaughter
everybody's safe around you
everybody's bullish
typing out walking tweets on a phone
made by child slaves
cut it out man
that is The Telltale sign of a
totalitarian Society is that everybody
is full of s-h-i-t that's how it goes
at every single level when Chris Rock
Says man you think I was I'm wearing a
wire that's people behave in a
totalitarian society as if everybody
else is wearing a wire
not just in your most public aspects of
life but even in the private ones
because in the totalitarian Society
every citizen is encouraged to rat on
every other citizen parents are
encouraged to rat on or children rather
are encouraged to rat on their parents
every social Bond beyond the bond
between the individual and the state is
dissolved that's what totalitarian
societies look like and we increasingly
are living in one
you can see it in China
very easy to say oh look at China but
they're doing that's so terrible that's
totalitarian it's harder to see it when
it's your own country even the way Chris
Rock points out he says you're you're
talking about how woke you are how much
you care about everybody you're you're
tweeting out you're woke slogans on a
device made by child slaves in China
but but here we we have a similar kind
of BS that we're all living through
we have to pretend
that men or women and women are men I
think this is one of the reasons why the
libs are so insistent on the transgender
stuff
because even though historically this
kind of confusion affects a very very
small number of people as a result of
the social contagion of a constant
inundation into transgender propaganda
many many more people are now
identifying this way something like one
in five Zoomers are identifying as LGBT
LMNOP so there is a social contagion
aspect to it
but the reason they push for it is the
same reason that big brother forces
Winston at the end of 1984 to say and
believe that two plus two equals five is
because if they can get you to say that
men are really women and women are
really men they can get you to say
anything at all and we have to say if
you don't say it you could lose your job
you could lose your school you could
receive death threats you can you can
have your physical safety threatened
okay and you will depending on how
vociferously you do that depending on
what sort of prominence you have From
Any Given stage that is how intense
these people are about it and yet people
still know the truth Chris Rock actually
in another great segment of his comedy
show talked about this with regard to
the fundamental right the right to life
there's a part of me that's pro-life but
since I love my daughter's
unconditionally I love them not just as
little girls alone as grown women I want
my daughters to live in a world where
they have complete control of their
bodies okay
okay
and because of that
I am pro-choice I'm absolutely
pro-choice okay I believe women should
have the right to kill babies
that's right I'm on your side
I believe you should have the right to
kill as many babies as you want
kill them all I don't give a
but let's not get it twisted it is
killing a baby cause whenever I pay for
an abortion I request a dead baby
sometimes I call up the doctor like a
Hitman is it done
he keeps going on and the best part is
you can hear the laughter kind of
trickle toward the end of that because
the setup was so perfect other comedians
have have done versions of this bit
Louis CK famously did one I think Bill
Burr may have done one but Chris rocks
is the best one I've seen so far
where it seems so persuasive at the top
I want my daughters to have total
control over their body
yeah
I am completely pro-choice
women should be able to kill as many
babies as they want uh
no I'm on your side
I'm describing I am articulating your
point of view
and you know there were some people in
that audience
Who had who are pro-abortion who had
never really been forced to think about
that
and it's it's wonderful when a comedian
does this because that that's one of the
points of Court Jesters is that they can
go out there and mock the king they're
the only people who can mock the king
and and so in a way they're the only
people who can really speak truth to the
king without without very much fear of
getting their head lopped off for it
so these people they're listening to
them
they say oh
oh yeah I guess it is killing babies he
says he was it when I pay for an
abortion I need a receipt what am I
paying for I need to make sure there's a
dead baby at the end of that that's what
an abortion is right no I'm on your side
and you can't help but wonder about the
people who sincerely never thought that
abortion really meant killing a baby
and then they hear that bit
and what happens that little bit of
truth that little that little truth acid
that that Chris Rock just poured on this
ossified edifice of our BS totalitarian
Society
starts to crack the BS a little bit the
scales fall from their eyes I'm mixing a
lot of metaphors here but I say that
little the truth the truth juice that
Chris Rockport
it dissolves the scales from their eyes
and they say oh
the BS that I was told by the regime
which is that babies aren't really
babies and abortion doesn't kill anybody
oh that's not true actually we kill over
800 000 babies a year oh that's pretty
ghastly what else what else does our
society lie about the rest of the show
continues now we have got a very
important woke Tick Tock for you
yesterday was woke Wednesday we were on
the road couldn't quite do it so it'll
be woke with Thursday we will we'll get
to that we will finally get to speak to
you in the chat mercifully become a
member use code Knowles daily wire.com
slash Knowles for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]